stock prices immediately sold off after
news broke that russia had invaded
ukraine and oil prices rose to more than
100 per barrel markets are moving up and
down as traders seek out new information
but you may be wondering why a conflict
in eastern europe would take the value
of u.s companies or raise the price of
gas for american consumers i'll detail
how global conflicts move the stock
market why the possibility of war in
ukraine has had such a strong impact on
oil prices and why this extreme
volatility might not last
stocks are considered a risky investment
because they are pieces of companies and
companies are dependent on customers
when customers are scared they tend to
buy less and reduced buying has a ripple
effect throughout an economy conflicts
like the one in ukraine can make people
around the world nervous because they
touch so many powerful and nuclear armed
nations
it's not just russia and ukraine the
united states china and much of the
european union are involved in this
conflict now markets are forward-looking
so even before it actually happens
investors anticipate that consumers will
pull back on spending that will hurt
companies large and small and because of
the global nature of the conflict you
could see impacts just about everywhere
so traders sell stocks this has become
something of a knee-jerk reaction
especially as computer-generated
algorithms drive larger chunks of the
market the algos read through millions
of headlines and make trades accordingly
in milliseconds based on programmed
expectations but we're seeing oil prices
move in the opposite direction even
though it's a historically risky asset
that's because what's more important to
the price of oil than risk is supply and
demand even if demand slows down because
consumers are fearful a conflict in
ukraine could have a much bigger impact
on supply russia is one of the world's
largest petroleum exporters it accounts
for 18 of the world's natural gas and 12
percent of its oil and much of that
flows through pipelines in ukraine so a
conflict between the two countries could
have a notable impact traders are also
worried about sanctions from the u.s
europe and others the u.s state
department has said its sanctions won't
target energy markets but that could
change
and russia could cut its supply in
response to other sanctions oil prices
also have a big impact on other
commodities most commodities are pulled
from the source and put on trucks then
on airplanes or ships all those things
run on oil so higher oil prices mean
higher delivery prices which feeds into
the overall cost that's why you've seen
the big moves in stocks and commodities
so far but this may not last in recent
years markets have been less responsive
to geopolitical tension that's partially
because consumers have been resilient in
the face of global conflict over much
the past decade it's also because
central banks have stepped in to push
enormous sums of money into economies
that has helped buoy companies during
times of stress and also distorted the
normal supply and demand function that
markets provide but with inflation
rising around the world central banks
may not be able to step in as they have
in the past companies and investors will
be carefully watching the conflict and
consumer sentiment but they will also be
watching how the federal reserve
european central bank and others respond
while initial reactions are pretty easy
to predict we are witnessing a new
environment for the market and the world
we are in unprecedented times and the
market will be moving accordingly
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe to
this channel for my latest videos on
markets
in the words the king of the south ti
life is like a chess move you need to
make your next move your best move i'll
see you next time
you